i may believe is that people are now
where to open new fragility about value
save from hotsites fragility and
leaving your microscope virus of
dispute these [ __ ] hormones are
essential to climate change escape from this
gang wallace birth of waters foot
arise leaves them all at risk my father
preference  nobody and my hopes that
fully understand that when recording
when taking professors e o patria tce a
cabbage leaf we need to restart and
recovering people where the need to
address the fragility of cows de cair
122 worldwide coverage and the free fire
fighting engine water that  i cried at
climate action tries his best of
cooperation on the digital space the
free fire in the and stronger earnings
and solidarity in ill people in the
translations are
aaa well esse activa que eu understood
sewer or this or I am in this law if I
own this people trying to  use
the penalty covenant racism xenophobia tu
divide but my feelings that i think
would really stand o  ut within the cover
is a new people will understand and by
its national cooperation and only by a
very strong sense of solidarity would be
able to not only overcome the cover and
beauty systems that addresses the
fragility of the monsters as you help me
in the two  and finance at home in the
switch' and the problems that lie with
me this problems of pandemic audio foi
cruz and is on the long is we he is
football team
european economy
i hope that it will see this link and
the need to have that really matters is
going beyond the list below the
countries that would benefit in the
first two and decision to the sims a
creativity now but on top of that aim
at being shown  that we have any effect
20 national coordination of the week
opens in 10 minutes the consensus on
inclusive nas and sustainability that
means that we are not going to spend
money on surface surface walls are
helping the b  rownie industrystock back
but you have been investing in renewable
energy and invest in the activities that
are promoting in a green economy that
means that will address the problem of
health was covered the problems of new
generation certnet enter this series
should give we can transmit necessary by
the problems of  the poorest people
is by others enrico enrico l by the
pandemic that will be able to give a
neve priority to education and to a
digital letters equalizer honda gold make
internet available for everybody and move
investing in the sims is small lol for
more smash  mouth waste and more cool
hygiene society as amended speech and
new soul contract in society and new
global deal at global level and the scenario
secret generous of heart is going to be
country will show in some countries for
many who believe the most is can you
believe  which they sleep cycle is
wonderful i have one direction season
and i wanna say alright it's alright
free more free skins cool fic  ar full
free markets are very important role in
the economy but it is clear if else care
for you will not be delivered by
feedburner i have marketing sanguines webcam
but i admit it is public services and what is
clear is now even the most free market
society is  the fundamental used the
public road to the poor of the fundamental lula
factory institutions sou de torcer and
also initiates to say that free markets
ball show the team without reset youtube
youtube market but with marketing policies in a
context it public policies have a
positive response to making markets
without your secret on some people say
don't tell say you want the sunshines
prime in this post go you want the
president of wins sixth international
world this is what now this space and
very easy and very detail universe he
will hurt o he plays come back with  these here
at the school on canvas are day and night
your special election in the economist is
all driving the day of politics all
there right glue three times bad
my name  is a synopsis of control galloping
so this is something that id be carmen
cli a universal veil of all countries
events to promote the developing
countries the developing countries we
are then how this together anda sai
sedes Irmã intervention we are in the sense
but we need to be  back in the same boat
beacon some are traveling super out some
are just linking to the breeze so if you
want to solve the problems that we have
together we need to be able to work
together and i will end up super proud in
some very close to you love  secret sheer
love you wanna talk about house weeks
without you still have a position to
register for evils and international
organizations and and one for your main
challenges to critical wars world is in
one so you get to the end
i say you now going to be posting  of
particles which cause i believe that
originate from institutions myth
beautiful homes huge your debt
acted i studied gave design after the
second world war distro ford o nt greenhouse
should have brought this mixture the councilor in
situations we are vertigo poor
leave feeling the other is calm saves
and even hurts less if misunderstanding
relations am iritua must even visual I
got rid of hunger of the signify silas in the form
of beto nudes institutions between hungry the
skeins are sent you  an das 5 episodes
that member state responsibility is not
the united nations and promotion of each
member state responsibility but it is
everybody whatsapp our institutions to
what is real and to the world